I am Katherine Maggie Ward I'm the
managing editor of Reason magazine and I
am here as your humble moderator for
this discussion of immigration we have
we have with us two esteemed scholars on
the subject Shikha Dalmia who is a
senior policy analyst at The Reason
Foundation and a columnist for I don't
even know how many publications is ours
ours most especially she is going to
tell us how Republicans are ruining
their party by becoming the Stooges of
Big Labor we also have Grover Norquist
who is the founder and president of
Americans for Tax Reform Arianna
Huffington has called him the Dark
Wizard of the Wrights anti-tax cult and
tell us about the perils of the GOP
anti-immigrant rhetoric we'll have about
15 minutes from each I think and then
Q&A from there it's thanks Catherine and
I just want to first begin by thanking
Grover because I asked him at a very
last minute if he could come and speak
and he was really really generous and a
real sport so thank you very much Grover
and he might be a Dark Wizard of tax
policy but on immigration he's just
absolutely right so you will hear from
him in a minute but so let me get
started soon after it became clear that
Mitt Romney lost last November because
Latinos came out in swing states and
voted in droves for Obama
Rush Limbaugh was absolutely outraged he
went on air on the air and said
Republicans have a problem and the
problem was not that Romney had
thoroughly alienated his Latino voters
during the primary by declaring that
he'd deal with the unauthorized
occurs in their communities by getting
them to voluntarily self-deport he said
the problem was that liberals play Santa
with big government and Republicans have
no counteroffer because they are
restrained by their limited government
principles so I'm going to argue
actually that nothing could be further
from the truth the reason that
Republicans can't win Latinos or other
minorities for that matter very rich
minorities like Jewish people and Indian
Americans and what-have-you and grovel
we'll get into that a little bit more is
because Republicans countered
liberals sent a version of big
government with with what I call the
Darth Vador idea of big government
so what Republicans show Hispanics and
other voters is not the humane and kind
version of limited government which is
what they could do to get them to vote
for them and nowhere is this clearer
than on the issue of immigration on this
issue Republicans are both the stupid
party and the evil party rolled into one
Republicans have been holding up
immigration reform in the house because
they say that till they have full border
security we won't support any plan for
citizenship for the 11 million
undocumented workers in the country so
to achieve this full border security
there is this border surge in the Senate
bill that has just passed and as part of
this surge what has the Senate done the
Senate has authorized 45 billion dollars
to build a double fence twice as long as
the one that we currently have on our
southern border they have also
authorized 24-hour drone and other
surveillance of the whole border they
have doubled the number of Border Patrol
agents from 20,000 to 40,000 so there's
going to be a border patrol agent every
thousand feet the 45 billion spending is
about five times what the bill
originally said was necessary to spend
on border security it is on top of nine
a billion dollars that we have spent on
border security since 9/11 this
represents a hundredfold increase in
particularly spending since 9/11 and
this is from the party of austerity in
exchange all that Republicans have to do
is agree to hand temporary working
status to the undocumented aliens right
away and then after ten years if all
these border security provisions that
will turn us into fortress America are
met then these aliens will be able to
apply for green cards and then five
years after that they'll be able to
apply for their citizenship that's 15
years starting maybe next year
by that time half of them are going to
be dead because they came a lot of them
came here because after the 1985 amnesty
initiative and you know and it's also
five years more than what Rush Limbaugh
himself said would be acceptable to him
he had said that he wants to deny
Democrat the Democratic Party POTUS and
he said if we give them some kind of a
green card but don't let them vote for
ten years it would be okay with him now
it's 15 years and it's still not okay
with Republicans so Republicans you know
are restriction is but what exactly is
restriction ISM now given that about 99
percent of the Mexicans who come to this
country come here to work restriction
and restriction ISM is basically the
idea of closed shop applied to
immigration policy unions fight
right-to-work laws because they don't
want union workers undercutting all the
sweet deals they have extracted from
their employers
likewise restriction is about border
control is simply a means of domestic
protecting domestic workers from foreign
competition
hence it is hardly a coincidence that
until 15 years ago restriction ISM was a
central plank of unions not Republicans
actually and no none other than vernment
breaks a pro-union Cornell University
professor gleefully posted in a recent
article at every juncture and with no
exception
prior to the 1980s the union movement
even directly instigated or strongly
supported every legislative initiative
enacted by Congress to restrict
immigration and to enforce its
provisions the Knights of Labor which
morphed into the American Federation of
Labor later on was wholly and solely
responsible for passing America's first
serious anti immigration measure the
1880 1882 Chinese Exclusion Act before
that America had virtually opened
borders later Samuel Gompers ironically
a Jewish immigrant himself who headed
the AFL for about thirty-eight years
starting in 1886 lobbied to have
Japanese included in this exclusion act
he backed off when Shaban agreed to
voluntarily restrict its own people now
this is exactly something all of you
lose something that you might know is
that this is the tactic that the big
three the automakers used a hundred
years later when they bullied the
Japanese government into voluntarily
imposing quotas on their car makers to
avoid even worse
trade restrictions in fact so our
immigration laws today look like what
our trade policy would have looked like
if big business had written our trade
policy but Republicans of all people
should understand that in a free economy
the market should regulate immigration
flows not federal bureaucrats or social
engineers employer needs should
determine which foreign workers come to
the country and in what numbers the
federal government's role should be
limited to conducting security and
health checks on foreign workers other
than that employers should be able to
hire whomever
whenever they want whether it is a
Florida farmer who wants Apple picker
from Mexico or Apple computer which
wants computer geeks from China but that
is not how our immigration system
currently works for starters it builds
this completely economically meaningless
distinction between skilled and
unskilled workers this your distinction
makes sense to bureaucrats but it makes
no sense to businesses for businesses
the two kinds of workers are those who
help them make profits and those who
don't and the creator profits means that
a business can expand and grow new
businesses can form the price of goods
and services goes down and real wages go
up in short cheap labor grows the
economic pie and if the pie grows then
there are more jobs for everyone I don't
have to explain to this crowd that in a
free market jobs are not a zero-sum game
but although foreign workers don't
threaten American jobs they have
historically threatened Union jobs
hence from Union standpoint the two
kinds of workers are those who threaten
it's chokehold and those who don't and
unskilled foreign labor has
traditionally been a big threat to Union
you know to Union struggles
hence unions have subdivided our
immigration who was into skilled and
unskilled categories and the skilled
workers get hostile treatment and the
unskilled workers get the equivalent of
waterboarding considered considered
first what skilled workers that
virtually everyone agrees are good for
the economy have to go through courtesy
big labor and all these rules have been
put in place by big labor as in front
and britni's it's offset daresay saga
begins when they generate a job offer
and their employer applies for a
temporary work permit called an h1 h-1b
visa but the gap of this visa is so low
that if you this visa gets filled within
ten days of opening up every year and if
the employers and the foreign workers
who don't get in this visa
they'd have to cool the
heels for another year and then they can
play the these are lottery again and the
odds remain the same now for the lucky
ones the foreign workers who actually
get a visa their troubles are only just
beginning the visa imposes draconian
restrict striction zhan them just for
the fun of it there's no rational basis
to this their spouses no matter how
qualified are not allowed to work they
can't change jobs if they apply for a
green card which is a permanent work
permit but to get the green card they
must get the Labor Department to certify
first that there are no qualified
Americans to do their job by the way the
Senate bill makes all of this infinitely
worse and we can get into that in the
Q&A this is just the current system the
current wait time for green cars for
Indian and Chinese high tech workers is
12 years so green card applicants are
essentially indentured servants of their
companies for about 12 to 15 years of
their peak professional career time and
high-skilled workers are actually the
lucky ones compared occurred restriction
Asst insists that unskilled workers must
wait their turn in a queue just like
foreign professionals do to come to this
country and get green crops but the
problem is that there is no queue for
unskilled workers temporary work visas
such as the h-2b that are meant for non
agriculture agricultural unskilled
workers which is the bulk of the illegal
population are even harder to get than
h-1bs
and that's because the gap on them is
just as tight as those for h-1b s but
the demand for them is four times
greater but that's actually not their
main problem their main problem is that
these applicants these poor Mexican
workers who need these h-2b visas they
have to show that they have property and
even jobs to return to back home once
that job over here is over but if they
had property and jobs why would they
want to come over here it's a catch-22
for them the real kicker is that you
know h-1b visa professionals they can
apply for a green card
while being on an h-1b but if these h-2b
workers if they if they're these are
official even like sniffs that they have
some in there
of staying in the country they are
permanently it is bought from again
applying for their reason that's the
system that they work under this is not
how it used to work in America until
about 1965 America had a guest worker
program called the bar cero program with
Mexico it was a special program with
Mexico that allowed Mexicans to very
easily get a temporary work permit to
work in the United States so Mexicans
could come and go with you know with the
availability of jobs but big label kill
this program because they think like the
competition and they replaced it with
the unworkable h-2b program and so
Mexicans who can no longer come and go
with the jobs have now you know they
were they were cyclical law-abiding
temporary temporary workers who came in
who came and went with the jobs now they
have become a permanent underclass of
illegal immigrants and this is
completely a feature of our immigration
laws so now Republicans have a choice
they can fix the laws or they can double
double down on this broken and bogus
rule of law and try and enforce it more
and since this is the stupid party what
are they doing they are doubling down
but the problem here is that you know FA
Hyack in his Road to Serfdom said that
when the government interferes with the
peaceful voluntary economic activity of
individuals in order to achieve some
collectivist and it returns even more of
her freedoms he said that it doesn't
matter whether these ends are
socialistic ones such as income
inequality equality through
redistribution all conservative ones
such as cultural preservation by
restricting immigration if these
restrictions leave individuals
substantially worse off they will fit
they will find ways to get around these
restrictions and that will unleash all
kinds of unintended consequences but the
government's failure to achieve its ends
will not be perceived as evidence that
there is something wrong with these ends
that they are maybe out of sync with the
normal aspiration
normal people rather the failure will be
blamed on an insufficient use of force
in achieving them thus an initial round
of coercion will inevitably spawn
subsequent rounds even more Decatur
Konya now this is the logic that is
playing on in the war on drugs and this
is also the logic that is playing out in
the war on immigrants so in the face of
widespread non-compliance with America's
immigration laws what have Republicans
done reformed these laws No I've already
mentioned they are building a Berlin
wall on the Rio Grande but what they
also want is more interior enforcement
this means that they want to go after
both illegals and the employers who hire
them this idea of employer sanctions was
first proposed by the American
Federation of Labor in 1986 now going
after employers involves you know
workplace raids that was Bush solution
and audit rails which are Obama's
solution and I don't think it's paranoia
to think that they might we might have
SWAT raids next just as we have in the
war on drugs the gang of eight bill
wants to enforce all employers also
wants to force all employers to
participate in a verified now a verified
involves paying $150 to verify the
immigration status of each potential
recruit foreigner or American against a
federal database the net effect of such
a law will be to require all Americans
to obtain a permission slip from the
government in order to work in other
words we are all illegal illegals now
till we can prove otherwise to our
government a verifier is essentially a
hidden employment tax and to make sure
that businesses pay it Arizona and
Alabama Republicans are resorting to
something called business death
penalties this means that if an employer
is caught with an illegal twice they
will revoke this employers license so in
other words they are shutting down
American businesses to protect American
jobs
so on one hand Republicans oppose
Obamacare employer mandate on the other
hand they are championing the equally
draconian either if I meant it
but it doesn't stop there many cities
are barring homeowners from renting
rooms to workers who don't have papers
Congress has actually thought about
prosecuting churches and soup kitchens
that offer free meals to illegals on the
grounds that they are aiding and
abetting an illegal act giving
undocumented workers a ride in your car
in Arizona is already illegal I'll let
Grover talk about the pot how terrible
the politics of all this are for the GOP
but just let me say this if Latinos did
not vote for Republicans in the last
election is it because they were
rejecting its limited government ideals
and wanted free goodies or was it
because their choice was between a
benign and beneficent Democratic big
government and a harsh and punitive
Republican big government Republicans
can scream all they want that this kind
and gentle liberal government is just is
a facade and that it'll come back and
become more draconian but if you are a
Hispanic what do you see what you see is
the immediate and instant danger of what
the Republicans are proposing to do to
you compared to this distant danger of
what might happen under a democratic
regime so what should the Republicans do
Republicans will win when they position
themselves not as agents of government
but as agents of individual choice and
empowerment concretely this means
support school choice religious freedom
and toleration eliminate the regulatory
Leviathan that crushes immigrant
entrepreneurs and cut taxes on small
businesses that ought to be the
Republican alternative to the free
goodies that Democrats want to offer
incidentally that has worked out really
well for conservatives in Canada Canada
and if you
what I can get into it more in the
question and answer session but Canada
has Canada's Conservatives have
completely switched the immigrant vote
and it's to the point that the Liberals
now complain that the Conservatives in
Canada want more open policies because
they want more voters so in short
Republicans have to become the jedis of
Liberty not the Darth Vader of big
government one of the reasons the
immigration issue is so frustrating is
that Republicans conservatives are
actually doing the other team's work as
was commented the restriction of Cesar
Chavez started his job as the first
minute man on the border with a baseball
bat trying to keep Mexicans from coming
over and competing with the unionized
United Farm Workers and somehow the
Republicans decided they'd take that job
over unions have traditionally back 100
years been the party against immigration
and it's so bad that back in the 80s
when I was doing college Republican work
and we'd work with other student groups
including Union finance front groups of
the left and we got a letter together to
support Soviet Jewish emigration and we
thought we'd get all the student groups
to sign it
none of the left-of-centre groups that
got money from the unions would sign it
because it might imply we'd let them
here they were that much opposed to
immigration so how do we end up in this
position one reason is that it's
misdirection you have a lot of people
that john o'sullivan
foreigner from britain used to run the
national
revue gave a speech one day and he said
you know immigrants come here they go on
welfare they become Democrats this is
bad we should stop the immigration and I
went up to him afterwards and I
explained to this foreigner that he'd
given a great speech against welfare but
why did he act as if he just given a
speech against immigrants most of the
people in this country who become
dependent on the state were born you
most people
go on welfare we're born on this side of
the border why are you worried focused
on the relative handful that come in and
he said well you're right of course
but we can't fix welfare we're stuck
with the welfare state but we can close
the border ok this was before 1996 and I
would argue that politics suggests that
handled right we can reform welfare we
made some real progress with aid to
families with dependent children and the
Ryan plan which every single Republican
in the House and Senate is endorsed
takes what was done on that block
granting AFDC to 185 means-tested
welfare programs that we have at the
national level and block grants them all
out to the state which would allow the
50 states to compete with each other and
you'd end up with dramatically lower
costs on welfare and fewer people locked
into welfare dependency but rather than
focus on getting that done and with Bush
Cayman we're at least for six months had
a Republican House Senate and presidency
he didn't go to block grant welfare you
focused on on other things and we have
some conservatives who where we should
be focusing on reforming the welfare
state for everybody have decided to go
shouted immigrants as if they developed
our welfare state for us you have the
same thing with entitlements the
Heritage Foundation which for 30 years
had a very strong Reagan Republican Pro
immigrant Policy Jack M Julian Simon all
that good stuff until they decided to
shift in 2007 but we the Heritage
Foundation did a study or claimed
insight into history they made you the
following assertion immigrants are bad
because an immigrant who comes in will
will receive three times as much in
benefits from Medicare as they pay in
taxes this is true of everybody born in
this country okay
the entitlement system particularly
Medicare but also to certain extent
Social Security pays out more than
people put in the things going bankrupt
it's going bankrupt if there are no
immigrants it's going bankrupt if there
are no other countries our welfare
system is damaging and expensive if
there were no immigrants so to focus on
being angry at immigrants for our
welfare system being angry at immigrants
for our entitlement system and again the
Ryan plant
handles the reform of entitlements and
particularly
Medicare in a way that ends that makes
it sustainable in into the future the
other thing some people look at and say
well our education our public schools
run by unionized bureaucracy doesn't
teach people English very well and
doesn't teach them American history okay
that's true for the people who are born
here their public schools
and somehow to blame foreigners for our
education system and if our government
school of monopolies seems to be silly
it's an effort by some people to blame
guys who can't vote against you
future immigrants they're not even here
right for our problems that we
collectively I mean I wasn't it on this
I say we everybody in the country where
we allowed the government to to make
these errors and so it's not just
everything that was pointed out they
were hurting ourselves by not allowing a
talent and youth and vitality to come in
and this idea that some people are
low-skilled yeah maybe today they are
but you know when you come in you get
skills your kids are a different story
so just this whole idea that we're
keeping people out of the country not
allowing the market to decide who and
how we hire people we moved away from
the whole idea of a guest worker program
more recently and allowing people to
come in and we do so with these bizarre
arguments of the left more people will
lead to environmental problems more
people will lead to entitlement systems
going bankrupt more people will reduce
wages because as as Malthus explained to
us there's a fixed amount of stuff and
every time we have more people we'll
just have a smaller fraction this fixed
amount of stuff the argument these guys
make our arguments against having babies
every bit as they are arguments against
having immigrants and it shouldn't
surprise this since the guys who
actually wrote a lot of the
anti-immigrant stuff are out of the camp
this it's not happy with babies as they
are with with immigrants the other
argument we get from some guys on the
right is enforce the law we're a nation
of laws be enforced a lot okay those of
us who are paying attention in the 1970s
when we had a 55 mile an hour speed
limit I don't remember
of course before the Fairness actually
didn't have radio talk-show hosts with
political opinions at the time but I
don't remember people standing up and
saying you know what there's all this
illegal driving going on and the first
thing we have to do is enforce the law
and arrest and find all illegal driving
and then after we've certified that
every illegal driver has been arrested
and fined or imprisoned we could then
have a conversation about whether 55
mileage speed limit is stupid okay these
are highways built for 75 miles an hour
and we have a law the Hells Angels had
that great billboard in California it's
not a good idea it's just the law okay
we had this 55 mph speed limit for
highways designed and cars designed for
75 80 miles an hour and the obvious
answer and what we eventually began to
do after 20 years of walking around was
we raised the speed limit and then start
and and then enforce it the speed limits
Montana has reasonable speed limit
things about nine
the we were doing fine with no speed
limits and the status insisting some
sort of speed limit somewhere but why
enforce the law makes sense if you have
reasonable laws if you have unreasonable
laws and our immigration policy it's set
at 55 mile an hour and we have an
economy that can take 75 and 80 miles an
hour this is the politics of this has
shifted a little bit back in the right
direction in 2000 1999 2000 a meeting
ten of us meeting with the head of the
Republican Party Jim Nicholson and it
was the major trade association its
chamber name and if I'd be retailers
truckers and me as mr. tax gun so we're
sitting around the table and they says
well what's important you people can
talk for an hour about what everybody's
interested to the Republican Party will
know and they went around the table
alternating between cut the capital
gains tax and take all the trial lawyers
and put them in a plastic bag and drop
in the river and so we did that and then
the chairman said thank you very much
has been very helpful II got up to leave
he's halfway out the door and the guy
from the Chamber of Commerce says like
in the second last scene in the Colombo
movies right well there's one other
thing well what is it and I said right I
don't have bring it up well what is it
well we never talked about what is it
it's about immigration or running out of
workers as 99 2000 and everybody that
around the table all the the business
representative said actually that Dwarfs
what I was talking about that's a much
bigger issue and they went around the
table and there are 80,000 too few truck
drivers and 200,000 too for you guys and
retailers on and on about the problems
they had with the shortage of workers
that was only going to get worse luckily
we had a recession solve the problem for
a while but
here you have the business courier the
biggest thing on their mind was
immigration reform and when talking to
elected to the two-party generator they
weren't organized organized labor has
been organized for some time on the
other side the business community bring
it up thought it was like burping in
public or something they thought it was
rude you know bring it up the various
communities of faith we're not as active
and now today the Roman Catholic Church
is very active the Southern Baptist
Convention overwhelmingly voted in favor
of comprehensive reform the LDS Mormon
Church is very strong on this the of
National Association of Evangelicals so
you have this whole collection sort of
underneath the modern Republican Party
you've got these politicians listening
to the echoes of radio talk-show hosts
who can be rich with a five percent
market share okay five percent of people
in the country listen John Brady you can
you can retire which okay with five
percent of the vote you can't get
elected dog catcher and so there's a
conflict of politicians listening to
guys who deal in five percent market
shares when they need to be speaking to
51 percent market shares if they're
planning on getting elected from time to
time and so you've got the radio talk
show hosts giving you an explanation
which works with their listenership or
at least with the guys who call in and
you now have underneath the Republican
Party every single business Association
of the United States and all of the
major and minor religious communities
now if the Republican Party isn't the
party representing people with jobs you
go to church from time to time you know
I don't quite know how they see their
demographic and yet that shifted
underneath them so I think some of the
negative stuff that we're seeing we can
move back I think we will end up with
something along the
of comprehensive but the biggest
challenges the costs of doing that as as
brought up earlier this border security
stuff the way to get border security is
to have a guest worker program a lot of
people to come here and work and come
back and forth
we dropped from 800,000 arrests a year
down 40,000 arrests year with a bracero
program under Eisenhower and then when
the union's got rid of it went back two
million arrests a year at the border it
seems to me we don't need the whole
border security and drones and and
whatnot we need a guest worker program
and yet the ours are all talking about
the idea of physical walls and the guys
would bayonets and moats and alligators
as if that was actually the solution of
a challenge and then worse is this halt
either RFI idea that we you know we set
up with Stassi here that would be
helpful and what they're willing to
sacrifice in the name of accomplishing
something that a guest worker program
would would accomplish 99% of any way is
I think problematic but that that said I
think we're moving slowly in generally
right direction of wrecking and the
other one is underneath all this even
ours will tell you we need more
immigrants we need
guys we need farmers dairymen it's don't
this is new to me 80% that people who
work in the dairy industry or without
documents that's rather high percentage
and there as we know because they passed
the evil milk subsidy laws their
powerful life in Washington DC so hoping
that the dairy people at least help on
this project and moving forward there's
a straw man that some people set up to
say Oh be like me or Karl Rove were
supposed to be arguing that if you pass
immigration reform that all the
Hispanics are vote for that's not what
either karl war i have said they're two
parts that's why it's not the hispanic
vote
it's it's all the immigrant communities
and that includes not only the guys who
are aged Americans Japanese Americans
Chinese American everybody Indian
Americans people of all those
communities have people in those
communities who are not here with papers
and they're worried about their friends
their relatives their co-workers it's
not just Hispanics it's not just guys
from this continent and it's not even
people who have immigrant problems this
decade it's people whose grandparents
and great-grandparents are telling them
stories about what it was like when they
were picked on so you've got this whole
community of people who see
anti-immigrant rhetoric as directed at
them even though you know Tom Tancredo
thinks he's only spitting at Hispanics
he's missing the point of the number of
people he's going out second is it's not
that you do this if you win all the
votes it's that you can't even have a
conversation about common ground until
we deal with the issue of threatening to
deport a million 11 million people you
imagine going to somebody and saying you
know and this this is some of the advice
we get from some conservatives well we
go to Hispanics again missing the point
that's not just Hispanics there were
irritating here the other Hispanics knew
say we're talking about you know we
agree on this pro-life issue and then we
want lower taxes and we're pro-family
and you're Pro family and look while you
and I talk about all this stuff we agree
on
egor here it's going to go upstairs go
have your aunt drag her down the stairs
and to our country but we won't allow
that interfere with the wonderful
conversation we're having
but all the stuff we agree on and
somehow they really think you can have
this conversation with that threat if
you remove the threat of mass
deportation then which is one good for
the country good for the economy when we
did amnesty in 86 the people who are
amnestied their income jumped fifteen
percent over the next year why because
they could change jobs they could
interview for a new job and not worry
about getting arrested
they could be mobile they could get
driver's licenses they got a bank
accounts all sorts of things they became
more successful and we could see that
with 11 million people instead of a few
million people so that question of
getting rid of this threat allows the
Republicans to do what the Canadians
have done and I've talked to the
Canadians they have a very very solid
position they're winning a majority of
all the various minorities in Canada
with a policy of being friendly talking
to them and other not terribly difficult
projects but part of it is at the
beginning at the end of the conversation
of being receptive to immigrants and to
reforming immigration so we're in a bad
place now I think we'll end up in a good
place it is to the interests of all
people who love liberty and to the
parties that try competently and
sometimes incompetently to defend that
Liberty that we do that thanks
you